So my name is Alex Kelly and I'm sitting here with Victor Kelli Zink.
Khaleesi [laughs] ummm, at the mayor's office for people with disabilities
And it's January fifth two thousand and thirteen. And this is for the oral world history project
though the New York Public Library visible lives oral histories of the disability experience.
And were just gonna to talk a little bit about your life today.
Great well, So I wanted to start out by asking you a little bit about, tell me where you come from
.
Well thank you Alex, I appreciate it. Um, Alex right, not Alexandra? Alex....
Either is fine [laughs].  Okay, okay....it's always good to see the name tags, it's easy for me to read.
Hum!
So, uh, where did I come from? My parents...
uh, are both, uh, from New York, and um, my mother's
My father is from Queens and, I grew up in Ozone Park.
Queens which is um, close to the Rockaways, not too far from Brooklyn.
so um, I get to like when I was growing up I had a.... best of
both Worlds because, uh, I had the Brooklyn side and the Queens side, so I was, uh
pretty fortunate to have, uh, both neighborhoods to kind of understand.
um.
So uh, where do you want me to begin? Memories from childhood
um, any, any early memories from your neighborhood growing up?
Yes... um, so I grew up, eh, mostly in Italian and Jewish neighborhood
And um, I'm from Italian roots my grandparents are from, um..
Italy, and I grew up in a great neighborhood, um, I.
I ah, I had one of the most amazing childhoods that anyone could ever have
Um, I had lots of friends, I had a close family... we would play on the streets
streets of uh...
Of a queens; uh, we would play stoop ball, stoop ball, baseball, we would play in the streets from
Um, We'd play touch football from sewer... sewer... sewer cap to sewer cap
Um, we would play...box ball and...we would
would stick ball and baseball and street hockey and...we just get...
would just get lost for hours and hours, um, playing, um...
I...I often joke my kids go to camp during the summer, and my
my...my mother's idea of camp was go out and play, um...
So it was... it was fun, I had...had a great childhood, I went to a... Catholic school
school uh Nativity Blessed Virgin Mary where, um, I ended up being an altar boy
boy, um, mostly to get out of class, to to serve Mass
and.. get out of math class [laughing]....um, and um,
...close with my...my siblings and um, parents were great.
always supportive in everything and everything I ever wanted to do. Um, so growing up in...in
Queens was...was...was great, um it was it was rough at times...um you learn how
learn how to stick up for yourself um, in the old fashion way
and...everything...everything I ever wanted or needed was there.
Tell me about your parents...
like....My parents.
[missing dialogue] is tough, and is tough, she um, she always pushed me to do what...I needed to do
do to get things done, she always believed in me and always told me I could do great things
and she's driving force...probably...even to this day, um, just, you know, hearing her
I ..I often, I often.
Often wake up in the morning and think about her and look in the mirror and say good morning, uh, to my mother [laughs]
but she's...she's a good woman, she's...she's tough and, uh, she gave me a lot.
lot. Um my dad...amazing guy.  Always..
Always was ah, supportive and always there at all my baseball games...growing up um...
always teaching me...new things. Always believing in me, so...
me, so the family support there was...was phenomenal, um...
um and I know you can always count on them, no matter what.
So...what was it like to leave the neighborhood, I'm assuming you...you left...
well that..that...  I wasn't talking to you here but...[laughs]
That's interesting when...how I became....how I came to leave the neighborhood
is interesting
It's interesting. So I was um, so after growing up in Ozone
Ozone Park Queens and that's where I really thought my world was, I didn't think it needed to be any bigger
than that. Um, and that's kind of the way we just grew up, and it was just
just all about our little world. And it wasn't until I became injured
injured, um, and had my spinal cord injury that I realized there's a much bigger world
bigger world...and that wasn't until...twenty
Twenty two. Um, so it was...you know it was, ah....
It's very close knit and you just felt comfortable where you were and you never got out of your comfort zone and you weren't really
weren't really encouraged to get out of your comfort zone as much, and it was fine and that's the world we lived in
in and wasn't until I got hurt that I realized there were a lot bigger things in the world that were out there
there...um...
So was that...that...that...that was interesting, um...
Um, and ah, once ah, so I got...I was injured
injured in a bicycle accident in 1994, the year the New York Rangers won the Stanley
Stanley Cup, because I'm a hockey fan, and...I was downhill mountain...
mountain bike riding in Queens, in Forest Park Queens, and ah,
it was a rainy day, and my friends and I...were...riding um
in the park and we were trying to figure out...you know
what to do, and it was a kind of a slow day, and I was really wanted to
pick up the pace, and right before we started to pick up the pace a friend of ours got
it hurt and he went home [ringing in the background]
And um....[movements] and he went home and I was about to go home
home with him and I didn't.
So. After that happened.... after he, he left
left, we...I wanted to pick up the pace, and I said let's go, let's pick up the pace so
we went to the top of one of the hills, and...my...everyone stopped, and I was like let's go
let's go...let's go... and we picked up the pace, and I've... decided to head down the hill
hill first. And when I did....from what my friends tell me, I flew over
my handlebars into a tree...and....
went head first into the tree and then fell down.
Um, and...the only thing I remember
remember is descending down the hill and that was it, I don't remember anything in between and then waking up
And when I woke up I went to go move my fingers and, I was like OK.
And I went to go move my toes. And when I went to move my toes I knew I was paralyzed
And from there it was, um, it was pretty tough. At that particular
particular moment. So [sighs]. Ambulance
ambulance came. Friends were supportive that were there
when I was biking with probably like ten... ten close friends.  Wow.  Yeah, it was a...a...
very close knit...neighborhood and we...we did a lot of things together
and when I got hurt it was...You remember being carried out and then going to the hospital, Jamaica hospital
Jamaica hospital in Queens, and then realizing...that my life is going to change
change...and...I remember it being in and out, and experience a lot of pain.
So.
My new life story.  And I was ah, I was born differently now. Um...
I was born able bodied and now I was born disabled and
life changed...so, um, then a new world opened up for me which I never knew
knew what...what..what that would be or where I was going was a new path.
So talk about that a little bit more, that..that kind of, that new world that...that opened up to you.
Umm, how long were you in...how long were you in the hospital for...and...
what was kind the transition like going from there, back home, and then
and to this new world [laughs]
So [sighs]...to re...to rewind, uh, just a little bit
Um, my high school was based in Queens and
and... I come from a long line of blue collar workers
And...come from
carpenters to mechanics to electricians, and
we
didn't really go to college, not many people in my family did, my brother was the first one
to go to college that I can remember, and
he went to N.Y.U. and our PAP was blue collar work, and we were OK with that
my dad made a really good,um, you know, good enough living...to support our family and give us what we
what we needed so I wanted to go to college.... I didn't want to go to college I wanted to be...
a blue collar worker, so I went to Thomas Edison in...in...Jamaica, Queens
Queens, and I became...a plumber, because they had plumbing class and I had a lot of blue
collar work there.  Ah, lot of shops, and I didn't want to be a mechanic
and I wanted to make more money and plumbing seemed to be...the way to do it your crap is my bread
and butter. [laughter in the background] Ah, so...
I was...I was a successful plumber.  Uh...I was about two years away from getting my plumber's
plumber's license, um I was doing well and so my life was...was...was pretty
good. I had everything and everything I needed, and my path was going well
into my career, and then when I got hurt, everything kind of
shifted...um. So, after I got hurt I was in the hospital and
and I was stabilized in the hospital, um my brother, Louis, did a lot of
work to get me in all the right places to make sure I had all the right health care
care that I needed and went to all the right hospitals. And I went to Mt. Sinai
Hospital. For rehabilitation.  And that...
that's when things just started to open up for me, so I got
hurt on July twenty.... sssss....
I want to say twenty fourth, twenty sixth, of 1994.
and I think in August some time we went over to Mount Sinai Hospital for rehabilitation.
.
And when I was there it was quite interesting because there were a lot of younger...
people with spinal cord injuries, because that's what happened...um...I injured my spinal cord, not sure if I said that earlier.
earlier. Um, and when I injured my spinal cord
.
..and...just....going to rehab, and I met other young people with spinal cord
spinal cord injury so it was really like this network of people that we were there together and we were all
all experienced the same thing, which was pretty helpful because it um...
it made me understand that I wasn't alone, and at...at the hospital...
I met an amazing physical therapist, Laura...Laura Crandell, and she was..
she was just amazing give me everything that I needed was real supportive in
so many different ways. She was not only physical therapist she became a really good
friend to this day and she's been here really. She has
been very helpful in who I am. So I got hurt went through
rehab found out lots of different things about myself my body
changed you know now I went from an able bodied person to a person now using wheelchair and
basically only using half my body because I'm paralyzed from the bottom of my chest.
So everything was different I had to learn how to. Get out
of bed to head it we're going to get dressed I had to learn to take care of my power plant
bowel and bladder because everything changes. How to push a wheelchair how to
transfer in a wheelchair. So all those things kind of you know as a twenty two year old
male you don't expect that to happen. Able bodied male so and then my
life was changed so I had to learn that through rehab and that's where everything was because
I had other friends too to learn from and go through with and Laura was
big in my physical therapy. And I
want to be active and I read I was talking to the lore
about that and saying what can we do. She's like well there's Wilcher basketball and everybody knows about
wheelchair basketball and I hated basketball and growing up that's
one of the sports that I just wasn't good at and we were playing roller hockey and my friends
and I at that particular time when I got hurt and I can never play hockey again.
So I was handed a magazine called Sports and spokes and that's
disabled athletes Sports Illustrated and it talks about all the types of different
sports that are. That are out there and I thought I
read about a sport called slut and reading about it was one thing but there weren't any pictures and I
was trying to figure out what it was about and I spoke to another
person in the disability world that was selling Will church at the time Dilly Lear
and I asked him about the sport cults that hockey is like oh I have a friend who plays who
plays it out on Long Island has it all great so he gave me his number it was Tony Fitzgerald
and Tony and I connected and in a slight Archy is a sport
where you sit on a sled on the ice with two i split underneath you and your
legs are out in front of you and you have two miniature hockey sticks
about two feet long ice pick on one and a hockey stick on your other.
And what you do is you have two sticks and you propel yourself across the ice in
a in a cross-country movement cross-country skiing movement and
that and you propel yourself across the ice and I thought it was great. And when I
went out and I tried it and it was a lot of fun and I thought it was
just for me just something to do. I didn't realize how competitive they can actually be
. So I went out all the time we played it and all of a sudden one
day we went to. This rink into national players came
out. It was Kip St Germain from Boston
. Massachusetts. Area not actually from Cape Cod
and.
Dave Conklin from Wisconsin and they were both on the national team and they came out and he skied it and when I
saw them skate they were just skating rings around us making all these turns
and doing all these things. Parkin lifting the puck in really playing hockey.
Wow wise how do we do that. So my friend Tony and I got in touch with
them and skated with them and eventually we were invited out to a national tour
and the national team tryouts or practices in Wisconsin. So here
here I am going you know generally two things New Yorkers do when they go on vacation when they travel they go
to real New Yorkers they go to Vegas or Florida but now
here I am going to Wisconsin
. So it was it was it was a culture shock you play hockey
right.
And it was kind of a culture shock to me and then things are just different. And
like I said I didn't get out of my neighborhood all that much when I was a kid and here I am in
Wisconsin and all the sudden we're playing in not only in this one in Wisconsin I'm meeting people from
from around the country Minnesota Wisconsin you know Boston
area and my world started to open up a little bit and start to travel
a little bit more detained. Then I'm in different parts of the country
and I got invited made in one thousand nine hundred sixteen
World Cup champion team that went to Sweden so let the
a Swede. So now I'm in Sweden and I'm starting to travel the
world and seeing a lot bigger thing and my world is really starting to
open up and the sport really helped
me deal with my disability. Meet other people with disabilities understand
what it's like to be an athlete with a disability and ninety
seven we got invited out to another World Cup team. We went to
Sweden and then in one thousand nine hundred eighty
I met I made the national team national Paralympic
team the first USA Paralympic slappy team and we were going to not going to
Japan and but in between that we were hosting clinics and traveling all around the country
and world for that matter. We were hosting clinics sled hockey clinics in.
Colorado and we were hosting slutty clinics in Dallas and then we were hosting site of
clinics in Philadelphia and we were just. Trying to grow the sport as we were
moving forward going to the Paralympics because we really wanted to get a lot more people
involved in in one thousand nine hundred eighty with the Paralympic Games in not going to Japan
. And it was one of the most amazing spirit experiences I've
ever had to be able to represent our country at a high level growing up.
We've always seen the Olympics and we always want to be part of that and dreamed about it and I
always wanted to be a baseball player and do some great things but I never got there.
But being disabled these opportunities were there and I was able to take advantage
of those opportunities and a lot of people with disabilities have opportunities now that they
never had that they were able bodied those were people that were injured after after
later on in life and it was just a world that was
like wow and travel the world and I never would have done that if it wasn't
for my spinal cord. And sport we did like
amazing things for me and I to this day I am committed to support
and helping young kids with disabilities. So
that's kind of my story about how I got from being
in Ozone Park Queens to really traveling the world and
and being part of something that no one can ever take away from
.
You know some of them credible people on the waves here.
I've met so many incredible people I met so many different cultures
and understand those cultures and being able to
. Just be part of it. She says
shape who I am today and without sport that never would have happened
.
Sport is powerful.
And you're in a pretty incredible position here too.
So do you want to talk a little bit about that. You kind of became
interested in politics for sure.
So as I was participating in the Paralympic Games I knew I had
to do. I knew I had to do something with my life.
And plumbing was not an option anymore. I could climb the ladder. I
couldn't shut off valve couldn't get down the basement.
So I had to do something different. And the thing that motivated me
. Was sport.
So I went back to school. I never thought I'd go to college and I
pursued a degree in sports and ministration at St John's University.
And through that I learned lots of different things about
sports in the business of sport. And Sports Marketing and so on and so forth. And I got
involved with a nonprofit organization that was doing
that was involved in adaptive sport adaptive sport disabled sport it's all
kind of the same so you may hear me say that so it's all interchangeable. And
I got involved with an organization called Eastern Paralyzed Veterans Association
and they serve veterans with disabilities and I worked in there.
In their sports department as a recreation aide what I would do basically I would go to
veterans affairs hospitals within within the New York area in Pennsylvania
. And
. So it used to be so I was working with Eastern Paralyzed Veterans
Association and I was working at V.A. hospitals here in the New York City area in
Pennsylvania and I was just
getting my feet wet trying to understand the disabled sports world and I was a
recreation aide and I was basically going to be a hospitals and playing
cards or. Or checkers with some of the guys at
bedside. People spinal cord injuries. At
some of the hospitals and eventually that grew into a lot of different other opportunities
and eventually putting on the disabled sports clinics and it can range anything
from hand cycling. To.
Track and field events to archery to air guns to
look for basketball program center and eventually I grew in that recreation aide
and with my education I went through the ranks of the P.V.A. Eastern
paralyzed their association and I did lots of different things in the
recreation department and started running clinics in Buffalo and Philadelphia in
lots of different areas of adaptive sport and that kind of gave me the basis of where I
wanted to do and then eventually started doing more and more things nationally and
and with the Paralympics having the Paralympic experience behind me being disabled athlete. I
started to get more involved in lots of different areas of sport
and I started to get involved. In
tok finding a way to tie able bodied sports and disabled sports together.
So I started to work with professional franchises here
in New York City like The New York Mets The New York Yankees the New York Islanders in the New York Rangers
and I really wanted to marry them I was organizations with disabled sport because it
would bring the exposure for the disabled athlete to show that they were under the big sports umbrella
and of these professional franchises and
also being able to show that person professional franchises care about people with
disabilities and you know it's a good synergy between Beau and eventually I was able to
secure sponsorships with all the major teams here in New York. So every
If you look at every disabled every sports team in New York City today they
sponsor a disabled sports team so I got involved with the National Hockey League in Major League
Baseball to kind of promote this and it was a model that I started
to use and eventually I rose to the ranks of the P.G.A. which later
changed your name to United sponsor solution. And I eventually became the
director sportsman working.
There and so I did a lot of stuff in between
. In between.
A recreation aide to sports marking another position that it held
at the newly named United Spano Association was director of special projects and
what I started to do there as director of special projects is
. Understand the government world of what they were doing so I would be going
to Capitol Hill and Bobby for
specific issues that they were looking to get
pushed in federal government you know things like transportation.
There was some stem cell research that we were they were pushing for.
We were pushing for health care initiatives
. So there was a lot of different things that I was doing and I was
took some of that those initiatives to Albany and
started lobbying in that and so that was just getting my feet wet in that type of.
Area and I never pictured myself being involved in government any way shape or
form remember I'm a plumber from Queens so you know
this is really interesting to me and what was happening in New York City about that
time when I was getting involved in all this government relations stuff was that New York
City was bidding for. The two thousand and twelve Olympic Paralympic Games
and they started to reach out to New Yorkers. Who were
part of the Olympic and Paralympic teams and they reached out to me and I started to get
involved in my experience with government and
accessibility and now sports all
tied perfectly into this Olympic Paralympic bid that we're going through so I was part of
that. The N.Y.C. twenty twelve Olympic Paralympic bid and was
involved on lots of levels where I dressed United States Olympic
Committee on why they should bring the games here the International Olympic and Paralympic committee of
why they should bring the games here to New York so I started doing a lot of that and they got me involved.
Worked on the accessibility of the villages that they were there were the people's villages that were there
and start to get involved and I was fortunate at that time
to run into that then parks commissioner Adrian Bennett Pete. And I
simply. I sat next to him at an event that we were
going to address the International Olympic Committee and they
were briefing us on something and I roll and I sit next to a person and I say
Hello Victor Cleese he goes Hello I major in bed a P and I was pleased to meet you
and then I realized who he was he was the Parks Commission. Very pleased to meet you. So
Adrian I got to talking and I said I really want to help make
parks accessible. For people disabilities because I've travelled
around the country and around the world in New York City to do better job because you know we are absolutely great
. So we started working with them on lots of different projects when I was with United on
association and Major and I struck up a pretty good relationship
and I started to do more work with the Parks Department
and one day I was going to talk to him and say you know I'm interested in the job but
he said there's a job available and you should apply and I was applied for the job
and it was called. It was an A.B.A.
coordinator and accessibility coordinator for the parks department and I
applied for the job and I was lucky enough to get it.
So now I'm working for city government and it was really interesting what was
happening at the time with the Parks Department is they were audited by New York state saying
they were deficient in seven areas of accessibility for people of
disabilities in the park system and they needed to. The
seven areas needed they needed to create a dollar threshold amount to
make ensure that accessibility. You know the money's being pushed towards accessibility they need to
. Have a grievance procedure on their website
they need to provide signage is the signage through the Porta throughout the park system
they needed to. It's higher
in eighty coordinator and they needed to come up with
an eighty wide transition plan and how they're going to go from
non accessibility excess ability. That's only five and I forget what the other
two are at this point which is just to be clear on that.
And my job now is task to to look at
the twenty nine thousand acres of parks that the city has and in those twenty one thousand
acres of parks or five hundred sixty five large parks and small parks thirty five recreation centers
fourteen miles of beaches twelve
historic houses. I pick them off with that number six hundred fifty
fifty six bathrooms and I have to know about and talk with people to do is need to get to an accessible
bathroom so the system is pretty big where the principal writer of sports
facilities in New York City. Recreation facilities. So I had a look at this whole system
and create a plan to make it accessible. So.
I started to get involved and figure out how we do this in the parks department had some model set up
that were there before but we look at those models and redefine them and we train
managers within the park system on what he codes and standards why are
we keep riding them with checklists to go out come back with these checklist and I had to
analyze all that data and put it into a document. The parks department tried doing this years and
years back. But never were able to come up with the full plan.
So I was able to within I think two years or so we were able to come up with a plan and address the
accessibility issues. From a physical standpoint point then we needed to really
look at their programs and services because
title and title to the A.B.A. says any programs or services that you
provide for people. Without disability should be providing
for people with disabilities so I had a look at the programs and services to make sure the
programs and services are complying with the Americans With Disabilities Act we had to look at their
capital projects and make sure that everything in their capital projects including excess abilities was a
lot of training that need to be done on their part and I have to
say through that work. New York City has to be if not the
most successful processing system in the world. I've been to other parts of it.
I've been to other parks and when I've been traveling around the country and around the world and
Chicago does a great job on accessibility in parks but the. Parks Department has it
right when they are looking at their designs there. They're talking about
making sure that everybody's included people with kids with autism where there's quiet spaces for a
man and looking at people with visual
disabilities and making sure this color contrast and people. Of all
abilities that are all encompassed now and in their design in making sure that kids can move through the
space regardless of their disability or not. So and now we
need a court there's a media coordinator still in place and they're continuing to.
I pushed that mission on him and then I through my
work with the parks department I was in touch with the mayor's office for people with disabilities on lots of different
issues because it just seemed like the proper synergy that needed to happen.
So I was involved with the commissioner then Matthew sapling was wonderful
Gary. Everyone loved and it's a great thing for this city for accessibility as a
whole and I think
it was a bunch of years into Matt's position here he
ended up passing away unfortunately. And the position opened and
I was fortunate enough to be able to have some people that pushed my name forward
. I interviewed for the job and
lo and behold I'm here and now I am the commissioner of the mayor's office for people with disabilities and
being able to drive the agenda for people with
disabilities is pretty.
Oh yeah you can see what I'm saying. The last position
so what.
So tell me a little bit about the changes that you hope to
see and accessibility of next years.
Well there's a lot and I mean our goal here is to make New York City more success and city in the
world and there are some cities that are newer than ours that have a big jump on us and it's
one of the you know great city that's accessible in Washington D.C. is accessible
but their subways are a little bit you know or they can have a great transportation system
. But New York City has some amazing things that make our city accessible. We were
the leader in buses back in in the eighty's we were building accessible parks
back then too. And everything that we do people around the
world.
Listen to so you know that's that's that's that's really
bad again. Now Mayor de Blasio has just really
championed signing and agreeing to making fifty percent of the cabs accessible by
twenty twenty which is going to set the standards I believe
through all of US cities for accessibility in cabs so that transportation model
in itself is is big and you know I expect that to grow and will
probably be even bigger than fifty percent but the market will dictate that.
And is just changing the perception of disability.
Here in New York City and no one wants to be seen now
. But over time you will either become
disabled be temporarily disabled or know someone that's disabled
it will affect you. It's just a matter of the way you're not going to escape this world
.
And you will address at some point your life so I'm trying to say let's be
proactive and let's think about including this stuff now. There's been a lot of work that our office has
been doing. My first deputy commissioner Robert
Piccolo's wrote a book called inclusive design guidelines that look at the Americans With Disabilities Act
guidelines and go over and beyond what accessibility is and really make an inclusive environment
so we're really pushing that in working with our city our city agencies to
really push that in part is doing a great job working with the Buildings Department designed contraption
the partner transportation to really make that part of the culture. So when they look at
accessibility it's just there we don't have to fight and argue that it's already budgeted for it's
already in there to be able to look at that. I want to be able to have.
Would serve the parks department really well as having that eighty eight coordinator there to be able to
guide the parks department as part of what they do now. And now other agencies
to be able to do that now the partner of Transportation has hired a
eighty coordinator pollers eighty analysts that's there is talking about accessibility issues that now it's
there it's all part of their process human resource administration is doing that
on the on the human resources side to be able to show that these things need to be
here too and there's other agencies that are starting to do this as well so we will have that point of
contact is extraordinary and just part of what we do. It's
not different it's just all inclusive so being able to build that model
is going to make New York City the most successful city in the world I have no doubt about that.
What do you know
. Yes yes I am very fortunate I have
a beautiful wife Susan and two and two beautiful daughters
Sophia and Lola you tell me about meeting in your life
my life. Yes yes meeting my wife we
were married for fifteen years now. As any marriage has its ups and
downs but I'm very fortunate to have such a great
partner.
That has helped guide me in so many different ways
.
To be so my wife Susan is how did we meet. Let's see
after two years after my injury. I met
my wife Susan. I was rehabbing at a facility called
Asphalt Green I was riding a bike.
It's called an F.P.S. bike functional electrical stimulation so
it would stimulate my legs and I would ride a stationary bike electrical
stimulate electrical stimulation to my legs and I would ride the stationary bike which would
help build up the muscle tone of my legs and help with cardiovascular
cardiovascular. So I was doing that and Susan
just happened to work there she was not my therapist you know to make that clear. She just happened to work there
and you know she came walking in and I remember hearing her boots and turning around saying
that so you know I started to get friendly with her
and I tried asking around. Turned down a couple times but I was a
little persistent and eventually she said yes and
we were at a wine tasting one night just as friends and it was
going to sing for years. The spinal cord research and
we were having a good time and my friend was happened to be bothering her and said you know your friend's a
jerk and I was like OK OK I know that you want to sit on my lap and
that was it. And we've been together since probably gathered for seventeen years now.
Yes She's she's she's a physical therapist and I figured I'd marry
a physical therapist why because they're cute they're active they make good money and
if I get hurt they can take care of me. So every time something happens just cause you some such
. Thing. The physical therapy Portas
the pullover that much as I expected to get to have two kids yes
. Sophia who's in seventh grade now
and Lola who is. In fourth grade.
So question I want to ask
your kids. Months and years from now or even next year.
What's what you want what you want done about lessons that
you learn from your from your own mouth.
Well I mean I think we try to show our kids how important it is to give
back and how important is to be involved. As I
mentioned how important it is. How much sport is
given me. I also realize that there needs to be someone that needs to be able
to drive that sport and I'm committed to working with an
organization called the Winter Sports Federation that helps people disabilities be
involved in sport and I'm also involved in making sure that kids with
disabilities have this opportunity for sport because generally a kid with a disability.
It goes to school and goes home. There are hardly ever involved
in other types of activities unless they find it in some way shape or form. So
being able to have a kid with a disability show up at school and say
yeah I scored a goal or I scored a basket or I travelled here like
every other their able bodied peers do is important to me. So sled hockey has
given me so much and I want to get back to that and we started a kid's team
and we have about thirty kids with disabilities all throughout the New York City area
. And we have kids from whom we have we have kids from affluent
families to kids who are inner city families and being
able to guide those kids and show them how important sport is at a very young
age to build. Their self-esteem and show them what they can do
and show them that they can easily be part of anything that they want to they can
be the commissioner of the mayor's office for people with disabilities. They can be the core
Council of the city of New York. They can be anything they want and being able to give him the
basis and show them that that exists is important and I
believe sport helps build that self-esteem so. I want to be able to give back
and that's important so I want to I want my kids to understand how important is to give back to
always be able to do that because I've been fortunate in life to get some great
things and I think it's important for them to understand that too. So
I think they got a good basis of that now that I can
I want them to continue to make a difference in people's lives and I think that's important
that's the reason why I'm involved in this and just knowing where I've gone and how fortunate
I've been through my career to meet the people along the way that I've been able to
give me what I need to move forward.
Is important and I think everybody needs someone to be able to do that.
And when the questions it's kind of a big question. Thinking back to
yourself. Age twenty two years. Final cord injury what
is yourself now when you tell somebody age twenty two
. You tried your terrorists that
happen and you were in the hospital and during that time what is yourself
. You know one thing that's really not that bad. It's great like
.
You don't see that when you first get hurt and I've
been you know they're there it's tough. It's always going to be tough and life is
tough you know it's just another obstacle in having an obstacle to overcome just make sure that much
stronger and having a disability that's probably
one of the best things in my life.
Best Thing That Ever Happened to me.
I'm.
Not sure I mean so much so my family and how supportive
. My family is very supportive
.
One thing I did fail to mention is how important my sister was in everything
that was there to you and me and my my parents were there. My
brother was there but my sister was also
constantly there is always there for me. I think that's important and
in my extended family is important to him that we're able
that have been supportive in lots of different ways. But in the end my
sister was definitely always trying to make it better for me.
Especially when you're in the hospital. She would we would ask for strange things and she'd
always come through with it we'd ask you to make it better so we can eat it takes practice. But
my sister was really it was really fun and exciting.
Yeah I had I don't I'm probably sure I missed a lot.
And if you think you think of something I can always come back here and record more. So
that's also something.
Yeah I mean we just wonder if I if I got enough.
Working with the disabled community. Enough about that.
What are what are some stories that stand
out from your time here.
There.
Was a lot Hurricane Sandy was it was tough working through Hurricane Sandy and
trying to get people disability and find out where everyone was and what
everyone needed and we we had a lot of success stories about being able to help people
get wheelchairs after a worry or get medical equipment or get people back away
from their apartments so we and we were doing an extraordinary amount of work during
that period to be able to help people disabilities and we're continuing. We
continue to help people with disabilities I mean there's some stories in being
able to connect people with all the right resources. We were fortunate here I
know at one point during especially during Sandy one of my co-workers.
We're able to save a person's life because they were on the phone
with them and found out that we were able to get some food there
and someone knocked on the door and no one answered and they opened the door and sure enough
the person was lying on the floor and they were able to call my mom one but if we weren't able to connect him to the food
resources. So if we were doing a lot around there and in a lot of
different ways you can try to connect to the stable community and have them have access to our office so they can
access the city resources something that we're committed to doing as well and we
continue to do that and we we want people to be connected to city services
because it's what we're supposed to be doing.
But there are lots of stories in getting kids connected and
gavel the sweet spot for kids. Tell me a kid with a disability and you
know figure out a way to help themselves and we're planning some great things for the twenty fifth anniversary of the
A.D.F..
I'm really looking forward to my July
when you plan on releasing all its
website upgrade times.
OK So OK so yeah so we are planning some great things for the twenty fifth
anniversary of a day for the month of July so please be aware you come out and check that stuff
out. More to come.
Freeze them so much it sound you know right now. OK.
Actually the Times has an article.
A little bit today. I saw that yeah I saw that about the parade. Yes yes. So
we're working on some stuff. Yeah yeah it's great to read.
Yeah it's amazing to me means smart because the
question is how many things you learned over the years how do you like I
mean you know your time initially starting at you know experience.
Yes you do you know to you know sports administration to
sport in general and I also went back to get my Masters two in
activity in Urban Urban Affairs to kind of understand our
government.
So yeah and this is a guy that didn't want to go to college and you know we
call it work road and I never thought I'd
succeed the way I was.
It's really it's been a great ride. It really has been very very very very
fortunate to to come into what I've got and I've got a lot of good
people on my side you know.
And so I went I went for him each summer
some of I think some of the great things that happen to me is when I got hurt
I kind of lost everything. I didn't lose my family support by a lost
. My job I lost my medical benefits
and have any way of making any money so I was on Medicaid and Medicare
couldn't get what I wanted. You know at the drop of
a hat and you know I had my family but I was and I used them only when I needed
but I you know I was you know I was I lost everything.
And I'm thankful for that because I understand what it's like
now. And I you know I could put myself in that person's shoes and say you know I know what it's like to be on
Medicare and know what it's like to receive Social Security benefits and not have enough to feed yourself
you know and make make decisions that you know I don't necessarily want to me make
you know I was fortunate to be able to go to my mother's house to be eat right so that was always an option
but there are people that don't have that option and you know that's real
and you know by losing everything it made me understand you know like I
get it and I and without social programs.
I don't know I don't know how would you know that Medicare without Medicaid without
being able to have the funding to be able to get financial aid
to go back to school without programs like Access V.R. which gave me
the resources to go back to school gave me.
They put hand controls in my car this is a state run agency that tried to get people
disability back into employment. They put hand controls in my car. They give me money to get
gas to put gas in my car. They paid for some tuition and they paid for my
books and there was just the social programs out there and if people
take advantage of these programs. Where they can they can definitely change your
lives. You know and I'm grateful for that and I know
firsthand and I can relate to people you could say well what do you know you have this is like no I
do know but it's hard to convey that message when you're this high people think you
know everything was handed to you and wasn't. But that's what's so cool.
Yeah it is really well with us.
Great hearing your story and you know thank you appreciate that
they appreciate that.
Yeah it's it's fun. Yeah. Fantine will change people's lives. It's
just for the for the better. It's what makes you get up every
morning. Makes you want to do better. You remember what his life was a phone
and phone.
Do you have anything else that you want to say it's recording
now.
Well yes I want to thank you. Well thank you and I want everybody to participate in the
oral history right.
We'll talk about how we can make that happen
. Yeah and I mean anything we need to put up on our website.
Anything we need to do just let us know we're behind it.
If you find. Some way that you tell us you want
to promote it just let us know. I think this is great I think it's important that people
disability lives are hurt and I
want everyone to do it I think it's important.